[Aplausos]
[Música]
11 de agosto del 2020 que da un poco más
de 80 días para celebrarse las
elecciones norteamericanas cuando el
candidato demócrata joe biden anuncia el
nombre de la persona que le va a
acompañar en su ticket electoral tengo
el gran honor de anunciar que he fichado
a kamala harris una luchadora por los
débiles sin piedad y una de las mejores
funcionarios de nuestro país como mi
compañera de carrera
joe biden en twitter nada más conocerse
el anuncio el partido republicano o al
menos el entorno político del presidente
trump abrió fuego
la elección de kamala harris ha
completado la toma del partido por el
ala más izquierdista y su agenda radical
marsha blackburn senadora por tennessee
yo vaivén no es moderado y haciendo de
kamala harris su testamento político en
vida está entregando el control de
nuestra nación a la mafia radical con
promesas de aumentar los impuestos
recortar los fondos policiales acabar
con los empleos energéticos abrir
nuestras fronteras y apaciguar a los
socialistas dictadores katrina pearson
asesora principal de la campaña de trump
en 2020 la decisión de dubai de añadir a
cámara
y que confirma todo lo que el presidente
trump y yo hemos estado diciendo es que
joe biden y el partido demócrata han
sido superados por la izquierda radical
mike pence vicepresidente de los eeuu
i
[Música]
amigos amigas de visual política la
estrategia de los republicanos tras la
elección de kamala harris ha sido clara
señalarla como toda una radical
candidata de izquierdas una persona
proveniente de los entornos más
extremadamente socialistas del partido
demócrata frente a ellos sin embargo
medios como el new york times 'los
ángeles times' o la visita la han
pintado como todo lo contrario como una
candidata centrista y moderada una
impresión que a tenor de las encuestas
es la misma que tienen los votantes los
votantes ven a harris como más moderada
que tram poppins y no sólo eso en los
círculos de análisis políticos se
consideró que la retirada de harris de
las primarias demócratas se debió en
gran medida a la falta de entusiasmo que
su candidatura generó entre el ala más a
la izquierda del partido en las
primarias repletas de candidatos
moderados el espíritu del pueblo en
algodón adform al tipo ayer vice sacando
nomination hasta enero primer ciento
afirmando así que la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es
en todo esto que punto de vista es el
que se aproxima más a la realidad y ojo
porque las respuestas a estas preguntas
resultan particularmente importantes si
tenemos en cuenta cosas como esta hayden
planea hacer de harris una
vicepresidenta tan poderosa como él lo
fue bajo obama el candidato demócrata
fue uno de los vicepresidentes con más
influencia de la historia
amigos amigas quieres exactamente kamala
harris porque vaivén la ha escogido como
su 'número dos' implicaciones puede
tener de cara al futuro estamos acaso
ante una futura presidenta de los eeuu y
la pregunta más importante de todas
quién demonios defiende la persona que
tal vez está al frente de una de las
vicepresidencias más importantes de toda
la historia de la democracia
norteamericana en este vídeo os vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas y lo
vamos a hacer echando un vistazo
precisamente al trabajo político que
hasta ahora ha desempeñado esta
candidata y os adelanto que nos vamos a
encontrar con una de cal y otra de arena
pero antes antes tenemos que ver
exactamente quién es
kamala harris atentos
[Música]
la historia de américa
se maduro por california y ex fiscal
general de este mismo estado harris es
toda una fan incondicional de las
zapatillas converse claro que esa no es
su característica más americana amigos
del perfil personal de kamala harris es
algo así como un sorprendente cóctel
formado por muchos de los atributos que
encarnan la sociedad y el conocido como
sueño norteamericano
harris es una perfecta representante de
las corrientes multirraciales
multiétnicas y multiculturales que dan
forma a buena parte de la sociedad
norteamericana en palabras de joe biden
su historia es la historia de américa un
momento creéis que exagero pues mirad
mirad kamala harris nació en 1964 en la
ciudad californiana de oakland una
ciudad situada en el área de la bahía de
san francisco que se ha convertido en
todo un crisol de minorías étnicas
apenas el 20 por ciento de sus
habitantes son blancos norteamericanos
pues bien el caso es que kamala harris
es la hija birracial de una pareja de
inmigrantes recién llegados al país su
padre jamaicano y su madre india los
inmigrantes que llegaron al país de muy
jóvenes
el paso de los años tuvieron mucho éxito
profesional su padre terminó dando
clases de economía en stanford y su
madre trabajando como investigadora
contra el cáncer y no sólo eso también
participaron activamente los movimientos
por los derechos civiles liderados por
martin luther king ese fue el entorno en
el que se crió la hoy candidata
vicepresidenta pero eso no es todo tras
divorciarse sus padres cámara pasó su
adolescencia en montreal para más tarde
asistir en washington dc a la
universidad howard una institución
históricamente negra luego nada más
regresar a california comenzó su carrera
jurídica luchando contra el crimen una
carrera que la llevó a ser elegida en
2004 como fiscal del distrito de san
francisco y más tarde en las elecciones
del 2010 como fiscal general del estado
de california un cargo para el que fue
reelegida en el 2014 y que terminó con
la elección de harris para el senado en
las elecciones del 2016 afroamericana
india hija de inmigrantes participé del
ascensor social y casada con un blanco
de religión judía para colmo es una
demócrata que ha construido su carrera
profesional en torno a la lucha contra
el crimen
del estado
de everything in my heart
amigos si tuviéramos que diseñar desde
cero el perfil de un candidato de una
serie política o el de uno que encarnará
como nadie el sueño americano estoy
seguro que estoy seguro de que el
resultado se parecería mucho al perfil
de kamala harris a ver por supuesto nada
de esto es lo más importante ni tampoco
es una garantía de nada evidentemente
pero sí son atributos que funcionan como
una especie de símbolo un tipo de
símbolo que suele ser muy importante en
la sociedad norteamericana y que además
explican en buena medida porque yo
bayern ha escogido precisamente a ella
maiden tiene casi 78 años el ya 55
vaivenes de la costa este
ella de la costa oeste vaivén como trump
y como pensé es un hombre blanco ella es
mujer y forma parte de dos minorías la
afroamericana y la india bailén tiene
fama de centrista y harris de moderada
pero más a la izquierda es decir en
otras palabras es el complemento
perfecto para la candidatura de vader
sabéis que las encuestas dicen
exactamente eso kamala harris es más
popular que vaivén entre las mujeres los
jóvenes y muy importante entre los
votantes negros y ojo porque en 2016 la
menor participación de la población
afroamericana fue una de las cosas que
le costó la presidencia a hillary
clinton pero amigos llegados hasta aquí
creo que ha llegado el momento de
hacernos la pregunta clave la gran
pregunta cuánto de izquierdas es kamala
harris o dicho de un modo más
diplomático qué clase de políticas
defiende y por qué esto es algo que
puede llegar a ser tan importante para
los eeuu pues bien atentos
[Música]
una de cal y otra de arena
amigos durante la mayor parte de la
historia de los eeuu los vicepresidentes
han pintado prácticamente nada la
vicepresidencia se considera básicamente
un puesto vacío de responsabilidad algo
meramente honorífico en la mayoría de
los casos los vices ni siquiera
participan en las reuniones del gobierno
simplemente estaban allí por si al
presidente pues le pasaba algo el de
vicepresidente es el más insignificante
oficio jamás concebido por la mente
humana john adams vicepresidente de
george washington y segundo presidente
de los eeuu el vicepresidente de los
eeuu es como un hombre en estado
cataléptico no puede hablar no puede
moverse no sufre dolor y sin embargo es
perfectamente consciente de todo lo que
sucede a su alrededor toma rai lee
marshall vicepresidente debut de wilson
sin embargo un momento porque esto es
algo que ha ido cambiando en los últimos
tiempos
en las últimas administraciones el papel
del vicepresidente ha sido bastante
relevante por ejemplo sin ir más lejos
de chay ni con george bush hijo y el
propio joe biden con barack obama
tuvieron mucha influencia e incluso
fueron responsables de algunas de las
políticas más importantes de sus
administraciones pues bien en caso de
que biden se convierta en el 46º
presidente de los eeuu la vicepresidente
podría ser una de las más importantes
sino la más importante de toda la
historia del país porque pues atentos a
noticias como esta la mitad de los
demócratas no creen que bailén sirva a
los 4 años la mayoría de los votantes
incluida la mitad de los demócratas no
cree que yo vidente 77 años sirva a los
4 años como presidente si es elegido
pero incluso de terminar su primer
mandato si es elegido claro lo cierto es
que vaivén llegaría a la siguiente
campaña con casi 82 años 82 tacos a ver
son muchos no me digáis que no
lógicamente eso hace que a día de hoy se
dé prácticamente por hecho que byd en no
aspiraría a la reelección y que por
tanto la administración podría dedicar
buena parte
esfuerzos a impulsar un candidato que
continuará su trabajo la vicepresidenta
por eso en esta ocasión es si cabe más
importante saber qué piensa y que
defiende la señora kamala harris así que
amigos dicho y hecho
veámoslo kamala harris más a la
izquierda que bernie sanders se muestra
el análisis de registros del senado
nuestro ranking ideológico colocó a
cámara harris como la senadora más
liberal en 2019 gop track un think tank
independiente y no partidista que
analiza los registros legislativos un
momento un momento la senadora más a la
izquierda entonces tienen razón los
republicanos cuando acusan a harris de
ser una radical pues no lo cierto es que
no no del todo o mejor dicho tenemos que
tener mucho cuidado con este tipo de
rankings porque se basan en premisas muy
generales
por no decir que cuando estás en modo
campaña a veces apoyas cosas a las que
luego no te sumaría si realmente la
decisión está en juego y lo cierto es
que la senadora harris ideológicamente
no es una política muy escorada a la
izquierda no al menos en todos los
campos me explico uno de los temas más
importantes y donde mejor vamos a poder
ver las diferencias entre el ala más a
la izquierda del partido demócrata la
corriente por ejemplo de bernie sanders
o casi cortez o elisabeth warren es por
ejemplo en el tema de los impuestos
veréis tanto la senadora y es candidata
en las primeras demócratas elisabeth
warren como la nueva compañía de joe
biden quieren que el sistema fiscal sea
más progresivo pero amigos lo quieren
lograr de una forma muy diferente ya
sabéis el está en los detalles
[Música]
las propuestas fiscales de estas dos
senadoras no podían ser más diferentes
mientras que elizabeth warren defiende y
llevará a cabo subidas masivas de
impuestos y establecer nuevos tributos
como por ejemplo un impuesto sobre el
patrimonio para financiar servicios
públicos kamala harris propuso la
conocida como leaf the middle class act
esta ley incrementaría la progresividad
del sistema fiscal mediante una fuerte
bajada de impuestos a las clases medias
ya las rentas más bajas la propuesta de
la senadora harris pasa por aprobar un
crédito fiscal reembolsable de hasta
tres mil dólares para personas solteras
y de seis mil para parejas casadas para
obtener este crédito hay que tener un
empleo y ganar menos de cien mil dólares
anuales para que os hagáis una idea
supondría una reducción de impuestos de
casi 300 mil millones de dólares anuales
que beneficiaría a unos 80 millones de
estadounidenses
la idea del crédito reembolsable
consiste en lo siguiente por ejemplo si
tienes que pagar cinco mil dólares en
impuestos federales y te diesen este
crédito de tres mil tan solo tendrías
que pagar la diferencia de dos mil
dólares y si por ejemplo solo tienes que
pagar mil dólares en impuestos porque
tienes un salario muy bajo entonces el
estado ingresa a la diferencia
es una fórmula que ya existe en eeuu y
que ha funcionado relativamente bien
como hay que tener un trabajo para
recibir estos beneficios pues digamos
que es un incentivo claro a no quedarse
en casa de hecho la experiencia nos dice
que los programas que ya están en marcha
han incrementado el empleo y por tanto
la recaudación de impuestos laborales y
de impuestos al consumo todo ello al
tiempo que se reduce la demanda de otros
beneficios sociales el resultado es que
el coste de los programas que ya están
en marcha que son dos ha sido
relativamente bajo
es decir reducen los impuestos y se
estimula una mayor actividad económica
así que puede o no gustarte este tipo de
planes pero no son radicales de
izquierdas al contrario la propuesta de
harris supone una reducción de impuestos
mayor que la cometida por el propio
donald trump y aunque es verdad que
quiere financiar la revertiendo parte
ojo sólo parte de la reforma de trump y
estableciendo además un impuesto a las
transacciones financieras que el
resultado final de la propuesta de la
vicepresidenta de bailén supondría una
fuerte reducción de impuestos
[Música]
luego por su parte otro de los campos
más importantes y que más polémica han
generado es el de la sanidad kamala
harris copatrocinó la ley medicare for
all presentada por bernie sanders una
propuesta de ley que pasaba por eliminar
los seguros privados algo que generó
muchísima polémica y que al final la
senadora terminó presentando su propio
plan un plan que mantenía así el papel
de las aseguradoras privadas en el
sistema medicare pero que reforzaba el
seguro público y sobre todo avanzaban
esa idea cada vez más extendida en el
partido demócrata de transformar el
sistema norteamericano en un sistema de
pagador único es decir en un sistema con
sanidad universal como muchos de los que
conocemos en la vieja europa lo único
que no detalla kamala harris es cómo
pagar toda esta transformación no
obstante frente a ella el plan by the
end no va precisamente por esa línea y
la verdad es que tampoco parece que la
senadora por california tenga el más
mínimo problema
ella es una pragmática
si es verdad aparentemente tiene unas
posiciones que tal vez estén más a la
izquierda de lo que ha sido
habitualmente la política de los eeuu
pero a la hora de la verdad tal y como
también le pasaba a obama siempre se ha
inclinado por conciliar estas ideas con
los intereses de diferentes actores
incluyendo el tejido empresarial tal vez
por eso en estas elecciones tanto
sillicon valley como wall street
van con la candidatura de bailén y
harris sissy me habéis escuchado bien de
hecho los financieros de wall street
están donando mucho más dinero a la
candidatura de bailén que la candidatura
de trump pero bien luego más allá de
estas dos cuestiones los caballos de
batalla tal vez más controvertidos de
kamala harris pasan por su apoyo a la
regularización de los inmigrantes
ilegales por dar una mayor facilidad
para entrar al país y por invertir mucho
dinero en el medio ambiente y la lucha
contra el cambio climático
[Música]
mucho esta ha sido una constante a lo
largo de su paso por el senado prometer
prometer y prometer más y más
compromisos de gasto público en total
según los cálculos de brian reid el
experto en presupuestos del instituto
manhattan
harris ha propuesto 46 billones 46
millones hispanos de dólares en nuevo
gasto público durante la próxima década
evidentemente ni siquiera a ella la
propia senadora piensa que sea posible
llevar a cabo todo lo que ha votado
prometido y el principal problema que
esto tiene no es ya que a la hora de la
verdad pueda defraudar expectativas sino
que sobre todo contribuye con su
discurso a creer el caldo de cultivo
perfecto para que discursos más
radicales como el del llamado socialismo
democrático de barry sanders o alexandra
ocasio cortez puedan crecer puede que
ella sea mucho más moderada de lo que
pintan en el partido republicano pero
hasta ahora no ha contribuido lo más
mínimo a fortalecer esa corriente en el
seno del partido demócrata
pero si kamala harris se llegase a
convertir en la cuadragésimo séptima
presidenta de los eeuu su principal
apuesta seguro seguro sería la reforma
del sistema judicial policial y penal de
los eeuu algo que a tenor de los datos
de criminalidad negligencia policial y
población presidiaria de lo que por
cierto ya os hemos hablado aquí en usar
política hace mucha pero que mucha falta
kamala harris apoya planes de reducción
de penas a cambio de formación laboral o
programas de reinserción quiere mejorar
la formación de la policía y limitar su
impunidad o su capacidad para utilizar
la fuerza mayor quiere también legalizar
la marihuana a nivel federal abolir la
pena de muerte y acabar con las fianzas
en efectivo que hacen que muchas
personas se vean obligadas a cumplir
años de prisión provisional antes
incluso de enfrentarse al juicio
simplemente por no tener dinero para
pagar las fianzas de hecho presentó en
el senado una iniciativa en esta línea
junto al senador republicano rand paul
y amigos no os equivoquéis no estamos
ante la típica candidata demócrata que
no quiere enfrentarse al crimen no en
esto muchas de estas iniciativas tienen
bastante sentido se puede ser firme pero
también a la vez pensar en cómo
solucionar estos problemas por ejemplo
cuando era fiscal general de california
para reducir el absentismo y mejorar los
resultados académicos lideró una
iniciativa por la cual se llegaba a
procesar a los padres cuyos hijos
faltaban sistemáticamente al colegio
algo que por cierto gustó mucho a los
republicanos pero poco a los demócratas
más a la izquierda de hecho su papel de
mano dura en california es una de las
cosas que más le critican los sectores
más de izquierdas en fin ya lo veis este
ha sido un acercamiento acaba la harry
es una candidata que sí es verdad
parecía estar más a la izquierda de lo
que ha sido habitual en la política de
eeuu pero que como by de no incluso
obama forma parte de ese tipo de
políticos pragmáticos que hablar de la
verdad buscan acercarse al centro
político pero seguro seguro que
tendremos la oportunidad de hablar de
ella en muchas más ocasiones así que
ahora es tu turno qué te parece kamala
harris qué opinión tienes de ella
es que la llegaremos a ver sentada en el
despacho oval dejaron sus impresiones en
los comentarios
ya sabes si este vídeo te resultado
interesante si quieres que hablemos más
las elecciones en eeuu es darle al botón
de like i suscribirte a visual político
ojo también a nuestro nuevo canal
hermano megaproyecto lo dejamos por aquí
un saludo y hasta la próxima si deseas 6
vidrios de skateboard ayer es hoy si
somos nuevo profesión y nuevos cambios